ça fait longtemps qu'elle n'a plus servi
alors dans la cuisine un coup d'épongé
s'impose non mais c'est vrai qu'on est
pressé quand même que ça que ça revienne
en à la normale tout ça et qu'on puisse
aussi profiter et fêter aussi cette
étoile avec les gens ça serait ça serait
vraiment top
parce que oui jérémie médard est un
jeune chef tout fraîchement tétouan les
récompenses et depuis peu par le célèbre
guide michelin
moi j'avais plus envie de pleurer
j'avais les larmes aux yeux c'est une
fierté quand même aujourd'hui d'avoir
d'avoir ce genre de choses on n'y
croyait pas c'est on n'y croyait pas
encore on a du mal même là encore
aujourd'hui accusé le coup et est vue
comme plus on la travaille pas au resto
donc danser un peu bizarre on l'a mais
on peut pas on peut même pas s'en servir
quoi alors pour ne pas perdre la main à
bellecin sachs ce midi ces noix de
saint-jacques plats d'exception et
toujours la philosophie du bon produit
on va essayer d'aller sur une pêche qui
va être durable là on est sur des
coquilles de saint-jacques que j'ai été
chercher chez mon producteur direct
enfin producteurs pêcheurs et on est sur
une coquille de plongée donc on respecte
l'environnement on trie on ne fait pas
n'importe quoi les fonds marins sont pas
détruits et ça c'est quand même quelque
chose qui me tient à coeur
un argument de poids pour le jury
michelin qui veille aussi
particulièrement ou techniques de
cuisson
moi je les cuis fortement d'un côté pour
pour avoir été très content des
résultats retourner rapidement en servir
que de fil d'ariane des cuissons
parfaites pour les accompagnements aussi
cette fois du fenouil au goût et à
l'odeur danis plus étoilé que jamais ça
sent bien le fenouil
mais le fait de les cuire comme ça on
concentre les arômes en fait c'est
vraiment assez intéressant à travailler
sur des cuisson sous vide et en plus on
peut maîtriser la le croquant ou le
fondant là j'ai fait une cuisson plutôt
sur du fond dans parce que feu doux
j'aime bien quand ça ce côté un peu
fondant à provale retire pour garder
notre gourmandise finir sauber le jeu on
va le mettre
donc premier ce côté un peu amusé avec
les barbes de saint-jeannet julien
médard est resté fidèle à ses principes
à ses valeurs une cuisine simple
travailler et sublimer j'aime beaucoup
mon terroir
j'avais le goût des produits et je vais
plutôt travailler sur d une cuisine de
goût sans trop dénaturer amené trop de
saveur le but c'est pas de faire un mix
de saveurs
le but c'est de prendre un produit le
respecter il a un goût spécifique on va
travailler ce bout là le corset
l'affiner prochain challenge pour julien
une autre première étoile verte celle
qui récompensent l'association de la
gastronomie et de l'écologie